Bradley Horowitz: Alright.
Are you guys ready?
Audience: Yeah!
[shouts and applause]
Bradley Horowitz: Alright.
I'm Bradley Horowitz head
of Product for Google+.
And we've done lots
of things in Charlie's.
We've had lots of
interesting events here.
But today is the first time,
to my knowledge,
we're going to host a Broadway
production here in Charlie's.
Are you guys ready for that?
[laughs] [audience shouts,
cheers, and applauds]
Bradley Horowitz: So as you know,
we're excited to host
the cast and the creators
of the amazing productions
of "American Idiot".
And Green Day band members
Billy Joe Armstrong, Mike Dirnt,
and Tre Cool brought
"American Idiot" to stage,
beginning with the Berkeley Rep Theatre.
Go Berkeley!
Here in the bay area.
So this is something of
a homecoming for the show.
We wanna thank SHN,
the folks that bring amazing musical
productions to San Francisco.
We wanna thank them for
bringing them here today.
For the Talks at Google series.
And for more info on the show
"American Idiot"
and all upcoming SHN shows
in San Francisco,
you can of course visit shnsf.com.
Or you can Google it.
To get going,
we're gonna start off with a brief video
that explains the creation
of "American Idiot"
So let's  through the video.
[rock guitar music plays on video]
Male Narrator: In 2004,
Green Day released "American Idiot"
and promptly revolutionized
rock music.
♪ I beg to dream and differ
from the hollow lies ♪
Male Narrator: Hailed by TIME Magazine
as a masterpiece,
the album launched the band
into super-stardom.
Selling over 12 million copies.
And winning the Grammy
for Rock Album of the Year.
While on Broadway,
Tony award winning director,
Michael Mayer,
was assembling one of the most
innovative teams in the theater
to joining with Green Day
and bring "American Idiot"
to the stage.
Michael Mayer: The idea of
theatricalizing this album
came to me just from listening to it
over and over again.
And hearing a very strong
emotional narrative
that was this story
of American youth.
Looking to improve their lives.
And I felt like that's just
such a great coming of age story.
Tom Kitt: I was able to hear a really
intense beautiful story right away.
There's so much here
that feels like
it's new and fresh and pushing
the boundaries.
That I think that
when all's said and done,
"American Idiot" is going to
have a very important place
in this rich art form
of musical theater.
♪ Don't wanna be an American idiot! ♪
Male Narrator: The stage version
of "American Idiot"
had its world premier at Berkeley Rep
in September 2009.
After two extensions,
and one record breaking run later,
the move to Broadway was inevitable.
John Gallagher: I play
the character Johnny,
AKA the "Jesus of Suburbia."
I kind of lead my friends
into this catharsis of,
there's gotta be something
else out there.
I don't know what it is.
But this can't be all there is.
Rebecca Naomi Jones: I think
immediately in the first time
that you see our characters meet,
there's this very quick kind of like,
there's something about you
that does something to me.
And he shows her almost
like a sweet gesture to her
that is funny to her and makes her laugh
and makes her feel warm
and less empty and less alone.
Ensemble: ♪ One, ♪
♪ twenty-one guns, ♪
♪ lay down your arms, ♪
♪ give up the fight-- ♪
Billie Joe Armstrong: We've always
thought that somehow
there should be some sort
of stage version
because that was what we were
thinking in our heads.
You know the musical arrangements
that Tom Kitt did,
you know, it's amazing.
And their energy is just inspiring.
Ensemble: ♪ Television,
dreams of tomorrow. ♪
♪ We're not the ones
meant to follow. ♪
♪ For that's enough to argue. ♪
♪ [rock music]
[applause]
Bradley Horowitz: Alright.
So after a smash run on Broadway
this past December,
the first national tour launched
to critical acclaim
and it's been a hit across North America.
They're here in San Francisco
for about the next four weeks.
And we're very pleased to welcome
the cast here of "American Idiot".
Here with us today.
So I'm gonna call off their names
and they're gonna come up
one by one.
And I'm gonna do my best
with your names.
Van Hughes.
Give him a welcome.
[applause]
Joshua Kobak.
[applause continues]
Scott Campbell.
Jake Epstein.
Gabby McClinton.
Nicci Claspell.
Leslie McDonel.
Talia Aaron.
Krystina Alabado.
Gabe Antonacci.
Larkin Bogan.
Jen Bowles.
Matt DeAngelis.
Dan Gleason.
Kelvin Moon Loh.
Tommy McDowell.
Jillian Mueller.
Jarran Muse.
Vince Oddo.
And Oke.
[applause] [cheering]
Welcome!
[applause]
Alright, we're gonna get
some mics for you guys,
those that are close to seats,
please be seated.
So I've got some questions.
We'll see where the conversation goes.
I'm sure these folks
have some questions.
And most of all we're here
to see you perform.
But, I wanna start out with
the opening of the show.
'Cause it opens with big crashing guitars.
Explosive choreography.
In your face vocals.
And I heard it's also very loud.
So what is it like to sort
of pummel the audience
that way with your first blow?
Van Hughes: Well, we call it
a punk rock assault,
theater style.
[chuckles]
Yeah, it starts with,
like you said,
like an explosion.
And for us too,
it's like getting launched out
of a cannon.
'Cause we do this show
eight times a week,
and it's pretty tiring.
I guess.
So we're all pretty fatigued.
But as soon as you hear that
"dah nah nah nah, dah nah nah"
That kind of like gets you going.
And the girls launch out
onto the stage
with fury of all hell breaking loose.
And you see it on the faces
of the audience.
I mean the audiences are like
"What is this?"
You know.
And then the show takes
a completely different turn
and kind of packs an emotional
punch by the end.
But we definitely start out
with quite the assault.
Bradley Horowitz: Yeah.
I think this is different than
any musical theater or concert
or production.
It's sort of like a new art form.
In a lot of ways.
It's different than anything
that's come before.
And one of the differences is that
almost all the narrative
is done through song.
There's not a lot of interstitial breaks
where you sort of get into deep dialogue.
The song is the story.
And I wondered if some of you
could comment on what that's like.
Is it harder to be constrained
by the songs?
Do you sort of wish there could
be more Greek chorus explanation
of what's going on?
Or does it work for you guys.
Okieriete Onaodowan: Well,
I know for me,
a lot of my friends and people
who see this show,
they really enjoy it
because it does have a way of
engaging the audience
and connecting with you emotionally.
Without the need of much prose.
Without all of that dialog.
Which is what's really beautiful.
And it also allows the show to
move at that breakneck pace.
Because there's not the time
to talk about things
and shift stuff and set all the things.
It's just go, go, go, go, go.
And everything is so well written
and the music is so rich
that you don't really need words.
Ideally that's why you sing
your musical theater.
Because words aren't enough.
So.
Jake Epstein: Well, it's interesting
because it becomes very personal
as an actor.
All of a sudden you
don't have words.
You kinda have to fill
in the blanks yourself.
So all the songs
that you're singing,
they come from you.
Because you don't
have any other choice.
There's nothing else to
kind of hang yourself on.
You have to kind of sketch out
your character for yourself.
A lot of it.
So I know that
when I first saw the show
as an audience member,
before I was in the cast.
Seeing all these people
sing these songs
and not knowing a lot
about them,
I saw these people singing these
songs as opposed to characters.
And I really connected with that.
Matt DeAngelis: There's such
a rich history and tradition
with rock operas in musical
theater anyway.
This is certainly an evolution
and it's a different thing
and it's crazy.
But like "Jesus Christ superstar"
and like "Tommy"
and shows that are completely
sung through
have always kinda had a place
in the industry.
And we,
well, not we specifically
but the creative team
and everybody took it
to a new level with this.
Which is kinda cool.
Bradley Horowitz: So are
you guys punks?
Or are you theater geeks?
[laughs]
Cast members: Both.
Yeah. [chuckling]
Bradley Horowitz: Of course.
Van Hughes: Well punk rock
is just kinda just saying
"This is what I am,
and deal with it."
You know?
So I think a lot of us
have that in our core.
Bradley Horowitz: Yeah.
I can tell from looking at you.
[laughter]
OK.
The bond of Johnny, Tunny, and Will
is evident from the beginning.
Van, Scott and Jake,
can you briefly tell us
who your characters are
and about the bond that they share?
And specifically do you
think this is like,
emblematic of a moment
when the album was released,
or is this sort of a characteristic
of bonding
that happens throughout time?
For youth.
Van Hughes: Well, I play Johnny,
the "Jesus of Suburbia."
And,
we start the play with me
having this idea
that we're going to leave
our suburban waste town
and see what else is out there.
Move to the big city.
So I'm kind of like rallying
my best friends in the world
to go for it with me.
And I'm like "Here are the bus tickets,
we're outta here."
You know?
And I think that's like one of
the most universal feelings
that anyone has ever felt,
especially in America.
Where you wanna go out
and discover what else there is,
you know.
I think it goes all the way back
to what Plato said.
About finding the real truth.
Like sometimes you have to ignore
what your family is telling you.
Because they're seeing you
a certain way.
And you just have to completely
embrace a new idea.
Scott Campbell: I like it
'cause these characters are drawn
in such a way where they really
lean on each other at the top.
I mean it's a really kind of,
typical kinda setup.
Where all you have is each other.
And you know you're stuck in
this monotonous day to day.
This complacency.
This need to search for something else.
And I mean,
we've all had our best buds
from high school.
And you know our family
situations as the characters,
vary greatly.
But one thing we have is each other
and when we,
when Johnny gets those bus tickets,
it's really like a uniting force.
And then of course we each
have our own pitfalls
and traps that we fall into
as our characters.
But the bond that we share as actors
on stage is really quite special.
Jake Epstein: yeah, the very
first lines of the song
Jesus of Suburbia is
"I'm the son of rage and love."
And I feel like that's the thing that
really bonds these three guys together.
They're angry dudes,
but they like love each other.
There's kind of a "bromance"
going on in the show.
And Michael Mayer.
Bradley Horowitz: So is
that with the characters,
or is it with you guys?
Jake Epstein: Both I guess.
Van Hughes: Both,
I think it translates to both.
I mean, we gotta swallow
each other's sweat
and everything every night.
Jake Epstein: We're spitting
on each other a lot.
Bradley Horowitz: Too much
information.
Jake Epstein: No, I mean it is,
at the end of the day,
"American Idiot" tells the story
of all these lost souls
trying to find their place in the world.
But at the end of the day
it is a love story.
Of a bunch of friends.
Who are there trying
to help each other out.
And they kinda get lost
along the way.
And then you see what happens
to them and where they end up.
Bradley Horowitz: OK,
so early in the production
"Boulevard of Broken Dreams."
It's sorta the first chance
the audience gets to breathe
after being,
assaulted,
I think was the word you used.
Van,  can you set up the song
and tell us about how you
approach it everynight?
Van Hughes: Well the song starts
with this monologue
which is one of the more direct
speeches to the audience
that my character gives.
And one of the lines
that really stands out is,
"The end of the world is over."
'Cause we explain that
the end of the world is sort
of our 7-11 parking lot
in our suburban town.
And this is the first moment
I've gotten to,
let's say,
New York City.
Or whatever big city we move to.
And I realize that
wow, this is like a whole
world of possibilities.
And the joy of saying
"I walk alone
and I can do whatever
I want with my life".
And I think that's
what the song's about.
Bradley Horowitz: Alright,
enough talking.
Let's hear it.
[laughter]
[applause]
[guitar riffs]
Van Hughes: ♪ I walk a lonely road ♪
♪ The only one that I have ever known ♪
♪ Don't know where it goes ♪
♪ But it's home to me
and I walk alone ♪
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ I walk this empty street ♪
♪ On the Boulevard of broken dreams ♪
♪ Where the city sleeps ♪
♪ And I'm the only one
and I walk alone ♪
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ I walk alone I walk alone ♪
♪ I walk alone I walk a- ♪
♪ My shadow's the only one
that walks beside me ♪
♪ My shallow heart's the only thing
that's beating ♪
♪ Sometimes I wish someone
out there will find me ♪
♪ 'Til then I walk alone ♪
♪ Ah-Ah Ah-Ah Ah-Ah ♪
♪ Ahhh-Ah ♪
♪ Ah-Ah ♪
♪ I'm walking down the line ♪
♪ That divides me somewhere
in my mind ♪
♪ On the border line of the edge ♪
♪ And where I walk alone ♪
♪ Read between the lines ♪
♪ of what's Fucked up and
everything's all right ♪
♪ Check my vital signs to know ♪
♪ I'm still alive ♪
♪ And I walk alone ♪
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ I walk alone ♪
♪ I walk alone I walk a- ♪
♪ My shadow's the only one
that walks beside me ♪
♪ My shallow hearts the only thing
that's beating ♪
♪ Sometimes I wish someone
out there would find me ♪
♪ 'Til then I'll walk alone. ♪
Gabrielle & Van: ♪ I walk
this empty street ♪
♪ On the Boulevard of broken dreams ♪
♪ Where the city sleeps ♪
♪ And I'm the only one
and I walk a ♪
♪ My shadows the only one
that walks beside me ♪
♪ My shallow heart's the only thing
that's beating ♪
♪ Sometimes I wish someone
out there would find me ♪
♪ 'Til then I'll walk alone ♪
Ensemble: ♪ Ah-Ah Ah-Ah Ah-Ah ♪
♪ Ahhh-Ah ♪
♪ Ah-Ah Ah-Ah Ah-Ah ♪
♪ I walk a -- ♪
♪ Ahhh-Ah ♪
♪ Ah-Ah Ah-Ah
I walk a -- ♪
♪ Ah-Ah Ah-Ah Ah-Ah ♪
♪ Ahhh-Ah Ah-Ah Ah-Ah ♪
[applause and cheering]
Van Hughes: Thank you.
Bradley Horowitz: Wow.
Uh,
Van, if you're gonna use any
more of that salty language
you have to give us notice
so we can bleep that.
[laughter]
Van Hughes: They said I could!
Bradley Horowitz: OK.
I'm just kidding.
We can handle it.
OK, cool.
So --
several of you were in the original
Broadway production.
And others have joined the cast
for the touring company.
For those of you that actually
weren't part of the original one
but were spectators,
that actually got to see that
in the audience.
Can you tell us what it's like to,
I guess first tell us your own
first experience of the show.
And whether you ever imagined
you'd be in the show.
And what it's like to sort
of be on the other side.
Matt DeAngelis: I think I might win the award
for the biggest "American Idiot" geek.
I saw it five times on Broadway.
Always in the front row.
To the point that
some of the actors,
some of whom I knew beforehand,
and some I didn't,
were like "Oh, Matt's back.
He's right there in the front."
I thought that it really
was genre changing.
Bradley Horowitz: Do you guys
have a name for those people?
Is it idiots?
female member: Idiots.
Matt DeAngelis: Idiots.
It was genre changing.
And I, like Jake said,
to piggy back on that.
I thought that the story
was incredible.
The music was incredible.
But the passion of the actors
was what blew my mind.
Just to see 20,
how many people were
up there on Broadway?
A couple more than we have now.
But 20 something people
just sweating and singing
and giving it every ounce
of energy that they had.
And on Broadway especially
if you're in the front two rows,
I mean, I was three feet away
from them
and it was the coolest thing.
Bradley Horowitz: How'd
you get those seats?
Matt DeAngelis: You get lotteries in
New York for those kinds of seats.
Bradley Horowitz: [laughs] OK.
Cool.
Anyone else.
Kelvin Moon Loh: Oh yeah.
I actually was an usher
at the Broadway house
that it was playing at.
And I remember it was my night job.
And some auditioning in the city.
And I came and saw it for free.
Sorry I didn't pay for that first ticket.
But I saw it,
I beat you Matt,
I think I saw the show as
an usher maybe 50 times.
[laughter]
And you know,  usually at that job
you're able to go out into the lobby
and you can just sit and read a book,
but I found myself drawn
to this show
and I called my agent up the next day
and said " You know what?
This is the thing that
I'm supposed to be doing.
I can do it all.
I swear to you,
I'll do the girls' parts, too,
if I have to."
So yeah,  it was quite an experience
and I am a huge musical
theater geek first.
And I've never seen
anything like this before.
And it's a remarkable piece.
Bradley Horowitz: So you guys do
the show every night or many times.
And does your relationship
to the content change?
Does anyone have a story about,
what it was like the first time.
Or what it's like the hundredth
time to get up there and do it.
Christina Alabado: I think
the coolest thing about the show
is that every night
we do it eight times a week,
so you bring something fresh
to it every time.
And the content is so emotional,
and it's so heavy,
a lot of it.
That it,
for me, I never have one show
that's the same.
I feel like I bring in
what I'm feeling that day.
Or what I just experienced
and it changes
and it makes it fresh every single time.
And that's the beauty
of the choreography.
The beauty of what we're singing.
Because the choreography is
so specific, Steven Hoggett's,
that you really,
you put yourself into it every time.
So it is set,
and we each do the same thing.
But it's with your own flair to it.
And stuff.
And that's why I think it's such
a cool piece to do as an actor
and as a human being.
Because it never gets old.
Ever.
'Cause it's just always something new.
Bradley Horowitz: That's great.
You wanna say something else.
You wanna add to that?
She nailed it?
Okay.
Cool.
Jarran Muse: Spot on.
Bradley Horowitz: So you talked
a little bit about the choreography.
I wanna talk about the creative
team behind the show.
Michael Mayer who won a Tony
for "Spring Awakening."
Music supervisor Tom Kitt who won
a Pulitzer for "Next to Normal."
Choreographer Steven Hoggett.
Associate director Johanna McKeon.
Associate choreographer
Lorin Latarro.
This is quite a group of creatives
that have helped put
this show together.
Do you guys work with them still?
Is that an ongoing relationship?
And what's that like?
Leslie McDonal: They just left today.
[laughter]
Yeah, they came to Seattle last week
to prep us for this city.
Just to check in on us,
you know.
And keep the show in good shape.
Fresh.
Bradley Horowitz: Are they
still meddling?
Leslie McDonal: Yeah.
All the time.
Jake Epstein: Well, from the last
question that you asked,
you're saying is it new every night?
It is new every night,
and so over time,
what was sort of set as
the show can become you know,
something different.
Stuff can get big.
Or too big.
And so every now and then
the creatives will come
and drop in on us
and kinda reign it back in.
They'll sometimes say,
just to like.
Bradley Horowitz: Or to concede
you're actually doing it better
than they ever imagined.
Jake Epstein: That doesn't
happen too often.
[laughter] But yeah. Maybe.
Leslie McDonal: I know
in the Broadway production,
11 months in our choreographer
came and said,
"Actually let's change the choreography
in 'Whatsername.'
Now do this,
and throw youíre
the way this way."
Just to like,
freshen it up a bit.
Bradley Horowitz: Mess it up.
Leslie McDonal: Not 'cause we
weren't doing it right, but.
Bradley Horowitz: Cool.
So another major member
of the creative team obviously
is Billy Joe Armstrong.
And he's so fond of the project he
actually appeared as Saint Jimmy
for a number of weeks.
Have some of you had
the chance to meet him?
And what was that like?
Gabrielle McClinton: He did
surprise us in Costa Mesa.
Which was amazing.
And only a couple of us knew.
Thank God I didn't know
'cause I woulda freaked out
if I woulda known he was there.
But that was the first time I met him
and I think a lot of us had met him.
And he was so warm,
and he loved the show.
Bradley Horowitz: So you met
him before the performance?
Gabrielle McClinton: That was my first,
no, after the performance.
Thank God.
But I know some of us,
some of the people in the cast
got to work with him.
I know Van did.
Van Hughes: Yeah, the last two
months of the Broadway run
I had played this role.
The Johnny role.
And the last three
weeks of the run,
Billy Joe Armstrong played
Saint Jimmy with me.
And it was so amazing
because he would switch it up
every single night.
I mean, to where he was like
grabbing me by the face
and making out with me
some nights.
And then like,
he proposed to me on stage
at the encore one night.
And like he,
talk about keeping it fresh.
We were playing off
each other so much.
It made this whole new life.
You know, and I had been
doing the show
for almost a year at that point.
So I mean, just to see
all the new possibilities
that could come out
of the show,
it was pretty amazing.
Bradley Horowitz: So,
speaking of Saint Jimmy.
There's a lot of speculation on
sort of what the character means,
on the internet.
Is he a drug dealer?
Is he a manifestation
of Johnny's addiction?
Or some sort of
combination of both?
So Joshua,
how did you approach the multiple
layers of the character
and what do you try to bring
to the performance?
Joshua Kobak: I try to
just enlighten Johnny
with all the wrong ways to do it.
Inside I'm trying to help this guy
and show him and awesome life.
Albeit through heroin.
Or crystal meth.
Or E.
Or glitter.
[laughter]
But, yeah, I mean,
he's Bacchus.
He's Dionysus.
He's the god of addiction.
That's,
you know,
he's not of this world.
The only person that really makes
that we really make eye contact
is me and Johnny.
Me and Whatsername.
She never looks at me.
I'll look directly at her
but she can't look at me
'cause I don't exist in her world.
It's kinda cool.
Bradley Horowitz: I have to say,
you're very well cast.
[laughter]
Joshua Kobak: I'll see you after.
[laughing]
Bradley Horowitz: OK.
There's another moment
later in the production.
The song "21 Guns"
that proves to be another
turning point for Johnny.
He's pushed to some pretty
violent behavior
at the end of "Know Your Enemy"
and is torn between his angels
and his demons.
Gabby, can you tell us
how you approach this song each night
from the point of view of
the character "Whatsername?"
Gabrielle McClinton: Well, every
night it's definitely very different.
I'm always feeling
an array of emotions.
It's definitely the most vulnerable thing
I've ever had to sing or perform
in my lifetime.
And right before it happens,
Johnny tries to kill me with a knife.
'Cause he's on a drug
induced moment.
Bradley Horowitz: Thanks to him.
Joshua Kobak: Missed it
by that much.
[laughter]
Gabrielle McClinton: So right
before I sing "21 Guns",
that happens.
My emotions are definitely
at the top
and just, everywhere.
I don't even know where to begin.
And as soon as the song starts
it's all about nurturing Johnny
and putting him before myself.
And caring about someone so much
that you would do anything
for them.
And,
yeah.
That's what she does.
Bradley Horowitz: So all
this drugs and debauchery,
we've heard lots of stories.
There's been a lot of talk
on the internet
about how that spills over
into the actual cast.
Any stories?
No, I'm just kidding.
[laughter]
Um,
[laughing]
Leslie McDonal: Go on.
Bradley Horowitz: OK.
So "21 Guns"
We're gonna actually have a chance
to hear them perform "21 Guns."
And after that
we're gonna be able to
take questions here live.
As you guys know
there's mics set up here.
But first let's hear the cast
perform "21 Guns."
[applause]
♪ [solo guitar plays]
Gabrielle McClinton: ♪ Do you know
what's worth fighting for? ♪
♪ When it's not worth dying for? ♪
♪ Does it take your breath away ♪
♪ And you feel yourself suffocating? ♪
♪ Does the pain weigh out the pride? ♪
♪ And you look for a place to hide? ♪
♪ Did someone break
your heart inside? ♪
♪ You're in ruins ♪
♪ Nicci Claspell: One, ♪
♪ 21 guns ♪
♪ Lay down your arms, ♪
♪ give up the fight ♪
♪ One, 21 guns ♪
♪ Throw up your arms into the sky, ♪
♪ you and I ♪
Scott Campbell: ♪ When you're
at the end of the road ♪
♪ And you lost all sense of control ♪
♪ And your thoughts
have taken their toll ♪
♪ When your mind breaks
the spirit of your soul ♪
Van Hughes: ♪ Your faith walks
on broken glass ♪
Jake Epstein: ♪ And the hangover
doesn't pass ♪
Ensemble: ♪ Nothing's ever built to last ♪
♪ You're in ruins ♪
♪ One, 21 guns ♪
♪ Lay down your arms, ♪
♪ give up the fight ♪
♪ One, 21 guns ♪
♪ Throw up your arms into the sky, ♪
♪ you and I ♪
Gabrielle and Ensemble: ♪ Did you
try to live on your own ♪
♪ When you burned down
the house and home? ♪
♪ Did you stand too close
to the fire ♪
♪ Like a liar looking for forgiveness
from a stone?
Nicci Claspell: ♪ When it's time
to live and let die ♪
♪ And you can't get another try ♪
♪ Something inside
this heart has died ♪
♪ You're in ruins ♪
Ensemble: ♪ One, 21 guns ♪
♪ Lay down your arms, ♪
♪ give up the fight ♪
♪ One, 21 guns ♪
♪ Throw up your arms into the sky ♪
♪ One, 21 guns
♪ Lay down your arms, ♪
♪ give up the fight ♪
♪ One, 21 guns ♪
♪ Throw up your arms into the sky ♪
♪ You and I. ♪
[violin fades]
[applause and cheering]
Bradley Horowitz: Alright,
thank you.
So those with questions,
please line up at either
of the mics there.
And in the meantime
I'm gonna fire off a few
while you guys think of some.
So there's been a trend
in the past probably ten years
to create musicals
based on a body of work
of a recording artist.
Things like Abba with "Mama Mia",
Billy Joel with "Moving Out."
Queen with "We Will Rock You."
"American Idiot" is unusual in
that it's not only from one group,
but from a single album.
The narrative of the play was
already present to an extent
when the album was created.
How much of the story,
we see in the play,
was fleshed out later on?
And how much do you guys
believe was sort of intent
upon the original launch of the album?
Leslie McDonal: The mention
of certain characters names,
I mean, how many songs do
they mention Saint Jimmy in?
Or like when he says [singing]
♪ Johnny says
it's better than here. ♪
And that's in "Novocain."
Almost every song mentions
one of the character's names.
Jake Epstein: It's actually Jimmy
in the original album.
Leslie McDonal: OK.
Right.
The name and we changed it.
So they mention the
names of Jesus of Suburbia.
We say that quite a few times
in all the different songs.
So it's clear that they were intending
there to be a through-line.
My character for sure
is a creation.
How do we explain, you know,
the song "Dearly Beloved."
There'll be a pregnant girl.
So there are certain things.
But Billy Joe did it with
our director Michael Mayer.
They came up with
everything together.
So it still had Green Day's ideas
as the influence
for how the story was fleshed out.
Bradley Horowitz: Cool.
OK, I see we have big lines.
Why don't we take on
this side first.
male #1: Hi. I'm really excited
to see you at the Orpheum.
So I have a quick question.
I know as an audience member
I'll take away tons of things
from the performance.
But I wanna ask you,
as a cast,
what's something that you
wish audience members
that would take away.
That may be a nuanced
gesture on stage,
or a thematic thing
that may get lost at the Orpheum.
What's something I can
keep my eye out for?
Jake Epstein: Well, I mean,
this is a personal thing.
But my character Will,
I never leave the stage.
I'm literally,
my character,
the three guys are gonna
go to the city
and I find out that Heather,
my girlfriend,
is pregnant.
So I stay behind.
And a lot of people don't know
that I never leave the stage.
So through everything going on,
check me out in the corner.
[laughter]
See what's goin' on.
Bradley Horowitz: This is like
an actor's dream role, right?
[laughter]
Jake Epstein: It is and it isn't.
Bradley Horowitz: Was it written
this way or did you just?
Jake Epstein: No, that's
how it was created.
[laughter]
Bradley Horowitz: Great question.
OK, let's alternate to this side.
female #1: I was wondering
what the audition process was like
for the show?
Nicci Claspell: Yeah,
it was different for everybody.
Me, personally,
I wasn't in the Broadway cast at all,
but I did audition for the tour
in Los Angeles where I'm from.
For me, it was a weekend
with a series of auditions.
You see certain people,
and you see more people.
And then you have to dance,
you have to sing some more songs.
There's other people for this tour
who were in the Broadway cast
who were asked to come back.
Actually Jillian there was supposed
to be in the Broadway cast
and then they had to close.
So right before she was
gonna start rehearsals,
she wasn't able to.
Unfortunately.
female #1: What about
for the Broadway production?
Jennifer Bowles: I auditioned
for the show a lot of times.
Many, many times.
And I actually didn't get it twice.
Because I wasn't quite right for
both tracks that I went in for.
And so I probably, total, auditioned
for it about eight times.
And then right before Christmas,
I just got a random phone call.
Just asking if I wanted
to be in the show.
And I kinda thought I was
being punked a little bit.
[laughter]
But it was true.
So then I started rehearsal
like that Monday.
It was a Friday and
I started it Monday.
female #1: Cool.
Jennifer Bowles: So, it was neat.
Bradley Horowitz: So, is there
a question behind the question?
I mean, you are at a mic?
female #1: No.
[laughter]
male #2: Yes.
I would guess that for this show
a lot of the audience
has heard the music
and the lyrics before.
How does that change things for you
as performers
when you're going
to an audience that
at least thinks they know the show?
Versus something that's completely
new to an audience?
Gabriel Antonacci: I think it's' actually
one of the things that helps us.
Because the audience
knows the music.
So when a song starts
that they know,
it actually,
you can feel a ripple
of energy sometimes.
You know,
for the big songs.
Like "Holiday."
Like "21 Guns."
Even "Boulevard of Broken Dreams."
Sometimes we'll get applause off
the top of those songs
because of the recognition.
Which you won't get in other shows,
which is great.
And also it's very cool because if,
for people who really
know the album,
once the song starts,
what Tom Kitt has done,
and the arrangements
that he has added.
Especially with things
like the strings
and we have Alon is our cello player.
You'll see him underneath
the stairs
if you come and see the show.
He,
it's so exciting
because the songs are so,
are taken so amazingly
from the album.
And put into our world.
So some audience members
are sort of sitting there going
"Oh, wow,  that's so cool
that they did that with this song"
And we sort of just heard that
with "21 guns"
being very different
from the album version.
But still such a gorgeous,
beautiful song.
male #2: So, are there disadvantages
of having an audience
that is expecting certain things?
Or that knows the show?
Leslie McDonal: Whatever someone's
expecting that comes to our show,
they will walk out saying
"I wasn't expecting that."
I think it shocks even people
that know the album inside and out.
We do things with the music
that they weren't expecting.
Jarran Muse: Yeah, and I think
a lot of the audience members
that I've encountered
don't know what to expect.
So they come in with little expectations
and are completely blown away.
By what they see.
There are a lot of fans
of Green Day that
couldn't wait for the show
to come out
because they bought the album
and they listened to it over and over.
So when they finally get
to come and see the show,
they're, I guess,
mesmerized with what they see.
Because it's pretty awesome.
[laughter]
Bradley Horowitz: Cool.
Yes.
male #3: Yeah, I have to say,
seeing it the first time,
I was surprised at the lack
of dialogue.
And the whole TVs and everything.
It just,
it was a real surprise.
But I loved it.
My question is,
I know doing a show
eight times a week,
it requires that much energy,
is pretty rough even when
you're located at home.
What's it like to tour and
what makes touring worthwhile?
male cast member: Well
[laughing]
Talia Aaron: Yeah, it's amazingly
challenging to try
and be as good to your body
and your voice and your heart
and all those things as you need
to be to sustain the show
like this when you're on the road.
I think the winter was particularly rough
'cause we were doing cities
in the East Coast
and we were doing mostly
one week engagements.
So we were traveling.
We were doing eight shows a week
and then traveling
on our day off on the one day.
And it's tough to make your mental
and physical and spiritual
and all those healths a priority.
But having each other,
having great people to travel with,
and...
I guess, the show also
is kind of its own therapy.
I find.
And I think a lot of us find that.
And so the kind of feelings
and frustrations and challenges
that you face traveling with it.
You kinda get a chance to work
them out every night on stage
in a creative way.
So.
Do you guys have a tour bus?
Or do you fly to the locations?
Cast: Fly.
Bradley Horowitz: Fly.
male cast member: Sometimes
we take a bus.
Bradley Horowitz: 'Cause you usually set
up in a town for a good while, right?
Cast: It depends.
Okieriete Onaodowan: No, actually,
on average we're in
each city about a week.
Two cities we're two weeks.
Here we're for four weeks.
And then LA we're at six weeks.
And honestly it's Sunday,
we close.
Monday, we fly.
And then Tuesday we open.
And that's it.
We have tech beforehand.
A quick sound check.
And then we open,
so just [snapping] you don't stop.
You don't stop.
Bradley Horowitz: So whoever put
you on the East Coast in the winter
and out here in the summer
needs a talking to.
[laughter]
Jarran Muse: Well, I think that that's
been one of the most challenging things.
You go from city to city.
It's climate to climate.
And you know this is a rock opera.
We're singing most of the show.
A lot of allergies.
A lot of vocal issues.
Some climates are dryer
than others.
And it's really hard
when you have to maintain your voice
and also maintain your body
because you have to
continue to go to the gym,
you have to continue to take care.
Denver, Colorado.
Bradley Horowitz: Well,
wait a minute.
Are you punks or are you divas?
Jarran Muse: Sorry?
[laughter]
Jake Epstein: Well it's even
you know,
audience to audience
is completely different.
Different reactions based on where,
politically, we are.
[laughter]
Sort of Red State, Blue State.
Especially because the show has really
strong political undercurrents.
So that kinda changes
what the thing is.
Bradley Horowitz: You feel safe here.
That's why four weeks.
Jake Epstein: We love it here.
Yeah.
Bradley Horowitz: OK.
Alright.
Cool.
More questions.
male #4: Hey. Going back to talking
about the arrangements
from the question before that.
The arrangements are awesome
with the strings
and the harmonies and stuff.
And I was just wondering
if you guys played around with
arrangements for other songs
that didn't make it into the musical
or even other Green Day albums.
'Cause I would buy one
or two more albums
of more arranged Green Day songs.
Leslie McDonal: Tom Kitt,
who he was saying won the Pulitzer
for "Next to Normal, "
he did all the arrangements
and Green Day fell in love with
his arrangements so much
that they asked him to arrange
the string parts on their next album.
"21st Century Breakdown"
Which is what "Know Your Enemy"
and "21 Guns" in the show is from.
So they were that obsessed
with his arrangements.
I know they did write some
stuff that didn't make it in.
Like people used to riff
in "Homecoming".
♪ Home, ho-o-o-o-me. ♪
And they were like "Never mind,
no thanks"
[laughter]
But a few things
that didn't make it,
but you know.
Most of it did.
Does that answer your question?
male #4: Yeah. No.
So there's no like, release tracks
that you're gonna sneak out or anything.
Bradley Horowitz: OK.
Cool.
male #5: Yeah.
Hi.
Thanks for coming.
I'm here on behalf of
the at Google team.
And I have some questions
from the moderator,
which is folks all over the world
which is asking questions of you.
The first one is from some idiot.
That's a term of affection
for you guys, right?
Greendayfreak88,
it doesn't say where they're from.
It says they've seen the show 11 times
and it's the best show ever.
And they wanna know what inspired
some of you to try out for it.
Joshua Kobak: Yeah, it varies.
Yeah.
For me it was,
when I saw it I was already
actually cast in a different show
and it was taking them a minute
to get me the contract.
And I happened to call out
of the show I was in
and go see it in Berkeley.
And it was at a time in my life
when I was full of rage and love.
Like chock full of rage and love.
And when I saw it I was like
"Oh, I need to freaking do that.
Because it's going to help me,
ultimately."
And so then I did,
I auditioned and then did that.
Matt DeAngelis: Yeah, I mean we don't
always have the luxury of being picky.
Like, we, our agents tell us
to go to an audition.
And we go and it just so happens
that some of the time,
if you're the right,
if you're right for the job,
you get a show that
will change your life.
And it will be artistically and
financially fulfilling for you.
And I think we've all
found that with this show.
And there are other shows
out there that are wonderful,
that are life-changing for the actor
and the audience alike.
And they're not all like that.
All theater is wonderful
and it's great to do it
and we're all blessed to do it.
But when you get a show like this
and you happen to get
the gig it's unbelievable.
We just kinda show up
where we're told.
Dan Gleason: And I think
for a lot of us too,
a lot of us grew up playing guitar,
and writing music and stuff.
So this is kind of a unique opportunity
to let our rock star and theater dream
kinda come to fruition at once.
You know?
male #5: Cool, can I get one more in?
Bradley Horowitz: Let's alternate.
We'll come back to you.
Yes.
female #2: At the risk of sounding
like a total creeper.
I saw you guys last night
and you were awesome.
But I have a musical theater
geeky question in that,
I've seen a lot of shows,
I actually do theater, too.
And like watching you guys
on the stage just rocking out,
and belting your faces off
while you're like head banging
and doing the crazy
awesome choreography.
How do you keep your tone--
this is like super nerdy--
how do you keep
your tone so straight?
I'm curious if you just like go for it,
or if you have techniques.
Jarran Muse: Technique,
breath support.
Our awesome musical conductor,
Jared Stein,
keeps us in check with vocal
warm-ups every day.
Van Hughes: It's also just
practice makes perfect.
Honestly.
I don't think anybody that
started this show was like
"Yeah, I got this" right off the bat.
I mean, it's just,
something that no one's
ever had to do before.
It's just a completely
unique experience.
So practice makes perfect.
Matt DeAngelis: Yeah,
your vocal cords are just muscles.
You know,
we've done this show.
Last night was show 179,
I think somebody said,
of this show.
And so after a while,
even on your days
when you do feel tired
and you are head banging and you go
"Oh my gosh, this is so hard today."
Your muscles still know
how to do it.
And it's--
Bradley Horowitz: Actually, your vocal
cords are just muscles,
but, yeah.
[laughter]
Gabrielle McClinton: Also breathing
is the most important thing.
Especially in this show,
your energy gets up here so much
'cause you're so intense
that you forget to breathe sometimes.
So as long as you
keep that breath going,
I think that is the key
to doing this show.
Dan Gleason: And confidence.
Like when we first started rehearsals.
There's a little voice in your head,
it's like
"Oh my God am I gonna crack on this
note while I'm pounding my head?"
And eventually that goes away.
So, yeah, you just kinda
go for it and it happens.
Bradley Horowitz: And how much of the
singing that we hear in the audience
is actually lip syncing?
I'm just kidding,
I'm just kidding.
[laughter]
[cast murmurs and chatters]
Matt DeAngelis: We've been
lip syncing all day.
For a year.
Male #5: I'll follow that up
with an actual fun question.
So this is from Arella in Seattle.
Who wants to know,
do you have any backstage
rituals before the show.
Cast: Yeah.
Yes.
Matt DeAngelis: Wanna do it?
Gabrielle McClinton: Oh yeah.
Matt DeAngelis: Should we do that?
Can we expletive?
Bradley Horowitz: Bring it.
Go ahead.
Jarran Muse: So, every day
before the show,
like right before the curtain goes up,
we all get in a huddle
around Johnny's bed.
And somebody shouts out
"One, two, three four
Cast: "Shit, motherfucker,
motherfucker, God damn!"
[laughter] [applause]
Matt DeAngelis: And also,
I'm a handshake geek.
In every show that I do I try to get,
we have a,
I think there's like 11
that have occurred naturally during
Jesus of Suburbia backstage.
We all have a big handshake ritual.
Krystina Alabado: Sometimes before
us girls run on in "American Idiot"
we mosh pit backstage.
And we run and ram into each other
until we have to run on stage.
Matt DeAngelis: And the ladies recently
have taken to when the curtain is down
they've been running
some track laps recently.
That's a new thing
that's been happening.
Bradley Horowitz: That's really cool,
we start our Google+ meetings
with the same chant.
[laughter] [applause]
Van Hughes: It works.
You should.
Bradley Horowitz: OK.
female #3: I thought it was
supposed to be confidential.
[laughter]
I have a TV related question.
So how do you guys feel about all
of the movies and the TV shows
that are being made about theater.
And life in theater.
Things that happen
behind the scenes.
Maybe, specifically Smash, or --
male cast member: Are
you talking about Glee?
female #3: No.
Actually I recently started
watching Smash.
So that's where the --
[laughs]
Kelvin Moon Loh: Well, Michael Mayer,
the director of our show,
also directed a couple
episodes of Smash.
Right at the get-go.
I think it's incredible
that as the years go on,
starting with Chicago
and all these new movie musicals
and these television shows.
It brings such a new audience
back to the New York theater
as far as I'm concerned.
There's a really vibrant young audience
that is now interested into
the Broadway musical again.
I feel like,
I believe these last two years,
it's been record breaking box office
years for Broadway seasons.
Which has not always been
the case with the economy.
So just to have this new
energy and this new interest,
resurgence of energy back
towards the Broadway stage
is very important.
And I think that's all being generated
by these movie musicals and
these television shows for sure.
cast together: Here, here!
female #3: Would you say these shows
are true to what actually happens?
And the process you go through.
Kelvin Moon Lee: No.
Comment. [laughter]
Gabriel Antonacci: I think we have,
I think a lot of us have a love-hate
relationship sometimes
with things like that.
But especially now the Les Mis movie
is doing live singing for their,
which is amazing
and that's so great.
And it sounds real.
Or at least hopefully it
will when it does come out.
But of course,
you watch Smash,
and everybody has beautiful apartments
and it's like, massive.
And they live by
themselves in New York.
In Midtown.
Where everybody here is like
"well, maybe not so much."
It is what it is.
But I think that anything that gets
more eyes on our business for us
is amazing.
female #3: What about
the competitions?
Gabriel Antonacci: Oh, like competitions
like American Idol
and stuff like that?
You know, I think that,
well, Tony Vincent,
our original Saint Jimmy on Broadway
was recently on The Voice.
I think it's different
for each person I guess.
They probably have again,
anything that makes singing,
makes people realize just how tough
a lot of this stuff is, I guess.
But I don't know,
is there anybody else who wants to
add something about the competition.
Okieriete Onaodowan: I mean,
it definitely does influence.
I don't know about me,
but just seeing especially with
American Idol and Sing Off
and all those shows,
they do greatly influence even
the style that music is written now
in musical theater.
With a lot of those shows now how,
the lead's vocal
parts and what they sing,
there's a lot more riffing
and all of that.
It's changed musical theater.
And that's good and bad.
People who, let's say,
do not have a standard legit
classic musical theater voice.
Have a notch.
Have a place.
And maybe people who do,
there's not as many parts
that are written for them.
It's as with anything,
it's a double edge.
There's lots of good
and like Kelvin said,
it's brought a lot of great attention
back towards Broadway
and they're back with everything.
Van Hughes: But I think as
far as competition goes for like.
I think, what you meant
is like on Smash, like,
Ivy and whatever
her other name is.
Yeah, I don't think anybody's
like stalking each other
to see who's gonna get the part.
I mean, I always think that
I'm gonna go out there,
do my audition.
If they want me,
they want me.
If they don't,
they don't.
I'm gonna get another job
down the line,
you know what I mean.
I think a lot of people
who are professionals,
that's just the way it works.
So you never know what
somebody can see in you
that you're not even sure that
you're putting out or not.
So as opposed to like,
going head to head in
the bathroom about
"Are you gonna get this part?"
I don't think it's really like that.
I've never known it to
be like that personally.
But it makes good drama on TV.
Bradley Horowitz: Alright.
Thank you guys for your questions.
We're gonna invite the cast
up for one more song.
"Good Riddance."
[applause]
Van Hughes: Thank you Google.
[audience cheers and applauds]
♪ [guitars strum]
ensemble: ♪ Another turning point,
a fork stuck in the road ♪
♪ Time grabs you by the wrist,
directs you where to go ♪
♪ So make the best of this test,
and don't ask why ♪
♪ It's not a question,
but a lesson learned in time ♪
♪ It's something unpredictable,
but in the end is right. ♪
♪ I hope you had the time
of your life. ♪
♪ Ahhhhhh. ♪
♪ So take the photographs,
and still frames in your mind ♪
♪ Hang it on a shelf of
good health and good time ♪
♪ Tattoos of memories
and dead skin on trial ♪
♪ For what it's worth
it was worth all the while ♪
♪ It's something unpredictable,
but in the end is right. ♪
♪ I hope you had the time
of your life. ♪
♪ [guitar riffs]
♪ Ahhhhh. ♪
♪ It's something unpredictable,
but in the end is right. ♪
♪ I hope you had the time
of your life. ♪
♪ It's something unpredictable, ♪
♪ but in the end is right. ♪
♪ I hope you had the time
of your life. ♪♪
[applause and cheers]
00:54:35.833,00:00:00.000